you ready yeah Ticketmaster all right  I'm on right now they go on sale in  three minutes  three two one no tickets available  refresh refresh should you find any no  it's a it's a no tickets available did  it how much five foot five hundred  dollars no change the quantity from two  to one  we're both try getting signals it  doesn't matter if they're next to each  other just try to get it what goodbye  goodbye what is wrong with your 45 mom  turn the ride on what kind of capture is  this this isn't a different language  what's that even say how are there no  seats available fresh fresh fresh  refresh refresh you're doing your best  here Ben you're doing your best focus  I got him Oh credit card declined but I  did everything right  you